here you are so good to the NFL you're a  fan you talk it up and yet you have yet  to play the halftime Super Bowl show no  desire I turned it down many many years  ago oh you did  I I didn't like this you know that you  had a team up with other people and you  had these people coming on your stage  and all the demands of and then the  pressures on it it didn't appeal to me  to play at the New Jersey one it seemed  too obvious the last time that honest to  god we were at all interested was back  when they had it in Dallas and we didn't  get it and I said that's the end of it I  don't want it I'm not even I won't even  talk about it again that is such a smart  thing John that is so wise I think  that's a lose-lose proposition is more I  ever liked it I like some of the  performances have been unbelievable  whether it was Prince or u2 or you know  there's been some amazing ones over the  years but not for me